i feel compelled to share with you guys
an insight that just emerged for us in
conversation about how to raise our
children you know these beings that we
love more than anything in the world
part of what we love so much about our
children is their innocence it is their
purity and we want to protect that
purity we want to protect these luminous
beings from
the the harshness of the world you know
i imagine myself having a son or a
daughter
and wanting to nurture and to protect
that innocence at all costs and so it
begs the question of course you know can
i be there to protect her forever and if
i cannot and i'm not able am i
committing a crime by not instead
preparing her for the world and so the
question is do we protect our loved ones
our children from the world or do we
prepare them for the world and of course
i mean
not
do we protect them from beauty truth
love and light these are the things i
want to nurture but it is their
innocence mostly that i'm wrestling with
do i protect their innocence from the
awareness of mortality do i protect
their innocence from the awareness of
death do i protect their innocence and
their purity from the fact that it's
impossible that's impossible you can't
do that you know you can't protect there
is going to be self-discovery of
mortality you can't protect them not to
discover mortality
yeah yeah but but that's but
die but have some compassion please for
that beautiful child right like have
some compassion for that beautiful
luminous being she's two years old she's
the light of your life she loves and
lights up your life okay and you are
sitting at your desk looking out the
window it's golden hour in a beach in
massachusetts and she's playing in the
sand
with the splashing water she's two and a
half year old your eyes well up you know
it's like a scene in a movie it's
postcard consciousness you are moved to
the point of tears you don't cry when
something is sad you cry when something
is more beautiful than you expected it
to be and this creature who is so
innocent and who you love so much right
no no come come there's bikes coming
this creature who you love so much this
being who is so innocent and so pure
and you're so moved by her purity that
you that you're that you're weeping you
you
are saying to me that you still think
that she has to be told she's gonna die
one day that she has to come to
understand that death exists
you don't need to tell her she will
realize that by herself but what a
that's a crime no that's not a crime
that's a crime well that's no i think
it's a crime
i think it's a travesty
i think it's i think
i cannot think of something more
horrific you know my mother says this to
me she's like you know she says i love
you more than my own life i mean she
would say this to me as a kid and it's
like or this this wonderful film i just
caught i just watched called
called beautiful boy about this
this kid who becomes a heroine and meth
addict and his father you know his
father has to
from the point of view of the father
imagine what that does to a father to
see a child suffering so horribly you
know that he couldn't protect his kid
from the existential anguish of a world
that would tell him that the only way
beyond his pain was through heroin right
it's the ultimate innocence lost and the
bereavement of a father realizing he
can't save the ones he loves and that's
what that whole video was that we want
to save those we love and saving
literally means protecting from the dark
not preparing them for a world full of
disappointment disease and death
but saving them from that world
keeping them in the garden of eden dude
if you saw that movie you would weep
because it's so beautiful and you want
to protect those you love that that much
don't you yeah if we if we if we could
protect
uh them from that that would be fine and
dandy but we we can't we just quick and
critical no we can't that's realistic
really it's critical that's realistic
okay we can we can protect them until
one point until we can't anymore and
when we can't anymore that's where
that's when they need to be prepared to
take the world on by themselves because
there's no more father and mother's
protection but i sense
in your
proclamation
i sense at least for a moment
uh invulnerability that i know is a
facade because i've seen you grieve
i've seen you you know behind the
glasses i've seen you moved i've seen a
little boy
in pain
and i when i see that little boy in pain
i grieve for that boy in pain and
ultimately that boy pain is like my son
or my daughter and the pain that i want
to protect them from and so again it
just it just begs the question and i
respect your opinion even if that
opinion is a profound psychological
defense scaffolding that allows you to
be a stoic instead of admit the
vulnerability of and pain and loss that
you no doubt have experienced as we all
have and i still
and and much much more okay you have no
idea how much more pain there is in
store for us and i'm not interested i'm
not interested through through perhaps a
force of will and will alone you know
through a force of ecstatic vocalization
and enraptured articulation i will
summon a narrative in which i can
protect those i love from everything you
know where love
can exceed everything
you know i i just
i don't know i just i i believe
i want to believe i live as if
in the halo of my love i can protect you
even from death
that's what i need to believe i can't
function i don't think without believing
that at least when i emanate that
towards those i love they are safe
because i love them
i mean
that's also what i need to say i need to
say that i can't function if i don't say
it like that
ultimately
we all are safe all the time because we
are in god's love you know okay there
you go and now you have come around and
now you have come around now you now you
have come full circle because you're
saying ultimately then we are all safe
not ultimately there is loss or pain
that is not everything will be okay at
the end and if it is not yet okay it is
not yet the end you know like
well call it the second law of
thermodynamics says what says no well it
says that everything's gonna decay
everything ends ah i don't like to
believe that but whatever okay um point
is i feel very strongly about this and i
wrestle with this and like
like ethan hawk in the film before
sunrise when he sits at midnight looks
at julie delpy and they're talking about
having children one day and he says
i looked at this kid and i couldn't
believe that i was looking at something
that was going to die one day
i just could never forget that
and i feel the same way
and i just wanted to share yeah
no it's it's you know it's uh i
it's not gonna end
ever ever like rumi said
don't grieve
because nothing is lost everything comes
around back just in a different form
amen
hope you're right